James Blair: Great thanks Rachael, let me start my share here,
James Blair: awesome great so today our topic like Rachel mentioned is RStudio and SageMaker,
James Blair: And like maybe I don't know if an apology is the right phrase here, but I have a two year old son who's very into spider man right now,
James Blair: And, as a result, I recently re watched into the spider verse, which is one of my all time favorite movies,
James Blair: And that's like heavily influenced the direction that the slides have gone today,
James Blair: So hopefully that makes sense and if not, we can just focus on the content unless on the style that they're presented in but but I actually kind of thought this fit because, as we go through this I consider both RStudio onSageMaker both,
James Blair: kind of superheroes in their own way in the data science space and we're excited about this collaboration in the ways in which they can complement and kind of work with one another and we'll we'll talk through that today,
James Blair: Again, as we just said, my name is James Blair,
James Blair: And I work as a solutions engineer here at RStudio,
James Blair: Just to give kind of an outline of the plan for today first we're just going to talk briefly about RStudio workbench i'm operating under the assumption that many of us are probably already familiar with RStudio or to do workbench to some degree, but for those who may not be,
Wing Kwong: we'll just,
James Blair: run through a kind of a brief introduction of what that tool is,
James Blair: will also do the same for SageMaker, and then we'll talk about RStudio workbench and SageMaker together, and what that offers will look at a little bit of a demonstration,
James Blair: And then provide some resources for you to continue learning on your own and then answer any questions that come up through the course of the presentation,
James Blair: So RStudio workbench is at its core an R centric development, environment, if you use the RStudio open source software, either at the desktop level or through RStudio server,
James Blair: you're likely familiar with this experience, you have a development environment that gives you lots of tooling around working with our,
James Blair: ways to manage packages ways to manage your environment edit files write code debug all these tools are part of the RStudio development environment,
James Blair: RStudio workbench gives you this environment accessible through a browser it's typically something that organizations will install host and manage within their own infrastructure within their own firewalls,
James Blair: we'll talk about how that models, a little bit different with SageMaker throughout the course of our presentation today,
James Blair: One of the things that that RStudio workbench provides that you don't find the Open Source version is, you have the opportunity to support multiple versions of our concurrently,
James Blair: And there's some additional functionality that's that's also available related to security and scalability in in RStudio workbench itself another kind of important component of the RStudio development, environment, especially as it relates to the topic today,
James Blair: Is that there are tools there for Python interoperability, so the ability to,
James Blair: Work in our in Python kind of simultaneously is something that's available and that's not restrictive just to RStudio workbench that's just a feature of,
James Blair: Really, the language but there's some tooling inside of RStudio the development, environment that make it a little bit easier to work with with Python frameworks within kind of within our context and we'll talk to why that's important here in a moment,
James Blair: Amazon SageMaker on the other hand, is a fully managed machine learning service, there are all,
James Blair: large and growing number of services available through SageMaker in fact at aws reinvent just last week,
James Blair: They have some new functionality and some new features that are being made available on the platform so it's continuing to grow, continuing to evolve,
James Blair: it's one of the fastest growing kind of aws products that that Amazon offers, and for good reason it's highly scalable it provides access to a lot of native machine learning algorithms,
James Blair: You have an integrated machine learning environment for doing development and testing and model deployment and things like that,
James Blair: And then, it gives you a really nice production ready way to deploy machine learning models track those models monitor than kind of everything, within the scope of model development and and machine learning operations is available through the SageMaker platform,
James Blair: With this said it might be kind of easy to look at these two different products and these two different platforms and to kind of pit them against one another right,
James Blair: SageMaker provides a machine learning kind of development, environment that's built on top of Jupiter lab they provide lots of really nice functionality and RStudio, on the other hand, provides a development, environment, heavily focused on the user,
James Blair: Thankfully, instead of putting these two things against one another, instead what's happened is we've,
James Blair: Combined the two,
James Blair: Right we've said look what if what if we have RStudio as an available editor isn't available tool through this,
James Blair: And that's a good name,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: In March, a real quick,
James Blair: And this this effort has largely been driven by the art community as our customer base has grown both professionally as well as just the Open Source users for us RStudio products every day,
James Blair: And there's been a growing interest in having some sort of solution offered through the SageMaker platform,
James Blair: and for good reason, right say Jamaica provides all these functionalities around machine learning and tooling that our users are likely very attracted to,
James Blair: But the RCD ID is the place where our users feel most at home and so we've worked closely with the SageMaker team and we're happy to announce that RStudio is an editor and an environment that is now,
James Blair: natively available,
James Blair: Through Amazon SageMaker and we'll take a look at what that looks like in just a moment,
James Blair: And we're really excited about this right, we think this is we think this is an awesome opportunity not only for us, but for,
James Blair: Our users kind of everywhere within within organizations throughout the globe, to use a tool and an environment that they're comfortable and familiar with, with a the enhancements provided by the SageMaker platform,
James Blair: So a little bit of a summary of what this is right it's a managed RStudio solution, which means that,
James Blair: running RStudio workbench onSageMaker means that as an organization,
James Blair: Or, as an individual, you do not need to set up install maintain RStudio yourself instead that's handled on the SageMaker site it's simply something that you choose to opt into and you set up your SageMaker domain,
James Blair: users and you know if you have an existing RStudio workbench license you can use that license and you can carry that over into SageMaker it gives you access to scalable Amazon resources,
James Blair: Easy access to additional SageMaker features and capabilities, like some of the machine learning abilities,
James Blair: And model deployment and management and other things that are,
James Blair: that are part of what stage make our offers to users,
James Blair: And you have flexible of compute resources for the different workloads that you might be involved and engaged in and we'll take a look at some of these things and an example here in a moment,
James Blair: So here's here's a just kind of quick little video and will actually look at this in real time in just a moment just to give you an idea of what this looks like in SageMaker on a on aws you go to,
James Blair: Open up the the launch APP drop down click on RStudio if it's been configured for your domain open up you'll you'll have the RStudio workbench landing page and from there, you can start a new RStudio session,
James Blair: it's really you know, like as simple as that is that the the powerful thing is that it's that easy to get in to get working inside of RStudio again fully managed hosted maintained by my SageMaker,
James Blair: And then just a,
James Blair: Just kind of a word that I think helps highlight the significance of this for us, but also, hopefully, the significance of this for the art community in general on this is a quote from truth, the, the President of RStudio,
James Blair: And he said, RStudio is excited to collaborate with the Amazon SageMaker team on this release,
James Blair: As they make it easier for organizations to move their Open Source data science workloads to the cloud,
James Blair: We are committed to helping our joint customers use our commercial offerings to bring their production workloads to Amazon SageMaker, and to further collaboration with the Amazon SageMaker team,
James Blair: And i'll kind of touch on that last component here which which for me is kind of a personally exciting aspect of this whole thing, and that is that we're not done,
James Blair: right but we're excited about what we've started here we're excited about what's available today,
James Blair: But we're also excited as we look towards the future and what we anticipate being made available in the near future and we'll we'll discuss some of what that will look like here towards the end of our conversation today,
James Blair: So, with all that said and done, let's go ahead and and jump in and let's look at a DEMO let's let's investigate what we can do what's available to us in this integration so i'm going to go ahead and switch over here, let me see if I can move,
James Blair: zoom controls out of the way so i'm going to open up here's my SageMaker domain on aws,
James Blair: I can see my user here in inside of SageMaker, and then over here, I can go to launch APP and i'll see that I have three different options here studio, which is the native SageMaker interface,
James Blair: RStudio, which is what we've been talking about here today, and then canvas is the new tool that was just announced last week that brings some sort of some some kind of no code functionality into into SageMaker,
James Blair: If we start with the traditional experience Just to give you an idea if you've never been exposed to SageMaker before and we've opened up SageMaker studio,
James Blair: This is the kind of traditional interface, through which developers will interact with with SageMaker,
James Blair: Like I mentioned previously it's built and heavily influenced by Jupiter lab but it's also heavily modified to provide lots of integration with the SageMaker platform and the tooling that that platform provides,
James Blair: So here we can see, I have different tiles that I can scroll through I have different projects that I can start I have different kind of,
James Blair: Work work streams that I can work on or different styles of projects that I can work on from within this environment,
James Blair: Now, this has been an environment that's been offered by SageMaker for for quite a while and our users may have have,
James Blair: experienced this environment themselves there's there's been support for our the language inside of SageMaker for a while and typically that interaction happens through through Jupiter notebooks,
James Blair: Now, if we come back to our SageMaker landing page and we go ahead and click on RStudio it's open this in a new tab here,
James Blair: Now we have and we get dropped directly into this environment that if you've used RStudio workbench before is likely familiar to you,
James Blair: Here we have our landing page where we can select sessions, that we want to work on, if we have currently running sessions, we can create new sessions, if we want to, we can view projects that we've,
James Blair: That we've previously opened over here on the right hand side, and we have some additional control over suspending or quitting the sessions that are running,
James Blair: we're going to be looking at this currently running session the SageMaker webinar here in just a moment, but before we jump in there and look at some of the content there, I want to go through the new session process, just to kind of showcase what's available here,
James Blair: we'll go ahead and open up new session here we can give this session a name example RStudio SageMakers session,
James Blair: that's too many characters will just say example RStudio SageMaker there we go and then here we can select the editor the only option available as RStudio,
James Blair: So that's one thing to be aware of, if you are familiar with RStudio workbench and you may be aware that it provides access to multiple editors beyond just RStudio those editors include Jupiter notebooks Jupiter lab vs code,
James Blair: With theSageMaker, and RStudio integration, the only editor available through RStudio is the studio editor the RStudio development environment,
James Blair: The other option that we have here is cluster again, the only option available to us is SageMaker, and this is just kind of an interesting note a little bit of a side note, but I think it's it's worth noting, and that is the fact that,
James Blair: Amazon is is one of the first groups that's taken the launcher,
James Blair: Which is a component of of RStudio workbench that allows it to integrate with other execution engines like Cooper 90s,
James Blair: But amazon's one of the first groups that's taken that and created a custom back end for it and that custom back end is this SageMaker back end,
James Blair: that's only available through the SageMaker integration, but once i've selected SageMakers my cluster I can then define,
James Blair: Will first talk about this image, I can define the docker image I want this particular session to be run on as it stands, currently there's only one default image available but that's something that will change in the near future,
James Blair: And then the instance type here is where I will select the easy to instance or the Amazon compute instance that I want this particular session to run on,
James Blair: And there's a whole host of options, and this is one of the great kind of benefits of this architecture, because one,
James Blair: I don't have to I get like I mentioned previously, as an organization I don't have to manage and maintain this right, this is something that set up as part of my SageMaker domain SageMaker, is the owner, the maintainer of,
James Blair: The RCD workbench environment but automatically out of the box if I if I go this route, I have a very flexible,
James Blair: kind of compute engine that I can lean on because I can decide when I start a new session, what type of resources, I might need Do I need,
James Blair: Have you compute Do I need to do, I have a very memory intensive process, am I going to be doing some really heavy model training with very big data, and I can make an,
James Blair: Intelligent selection at this point about what type of easy to instance I want this particular this particular session to run on so that I have the appropriate resources available to me, as I run this session,
James Blair: The other thing that's worth noting here is that as multiple users are engaged with RStudio through SageMaker they're working kind of independently in their own environments, so that if one user,
James Blair: does something in their environment, for example, reads data in the consumes all available memory or consumes all available cpu,
James Blair: They don't impact or negatively impact the other users, because they're all kind of in their independent environments,
James Blair: i'm gonna go ahead and select the default image here start the session will see a new session starting up right here,
James Blair: Now, because we're provisioning a separate new environment when we come in and start a session inside of SageMaker in the way that we've just done,
James Blair: It can sometimes take a long time to to start this initial session because it takes it takes some time to provision, the environment,
James Blair: Make the docker image available get that image running in a container get everything up and running, so that we have access to RStudio session, but once that initial startup is complete,
James Blair: That session is available and subsequent sessions will start much more quickly, and here we see this session didn't take too long to take it up and running,
James Blair: let's go ahead and come in here and just see what we have available and again if you've used zoom in a little bit here,
James Blair: I can go if you've used, you know RStudio previously, whether at the desktop level open source on the server RStudio workbench in in any case,
James Blair: This environment likely feels very familiar to you i've got packages that I can scroll through down here, I can navigate my file system here,
James Blair: I can look at help for different functions, I can navigate and explore my environment i've got the console here, I can execute our commands I have this document pulled open, where I can,
James Blair: You know i've got my editor I can open up our scripts are marked on documents anything that I want to to work with in this context,
James Blair: And a couple of things just kind of technically speaking, that are worth noting is one,
James Blair: Amazon automatically associates make are automatically mounts a home directory into every session so you'll see down here in the bottom right hand corner, when I look at files,
James Blair: I have a home directory available to me inside this home directory home directory is persistent,
James Blair: So this is nice because this means that if I am working on a project, and I let's say that i'm I started project and SageMaker,
James Blair: And I realized part of the way through that i've under provision my environment I didn't give myself enough resources and and if I want to be able to conclude my analysis I need to do it on a in a more,
James Blair: heavily provisioned environment, well, I can terminate my existing session I can save my changes, first of all terminate my existing session start a new session with a new bigger environment, based on what i've learned from from the previous session,
James Blair: And then, once that environment starts up all have access back to the same files, I was working on previously within my home directory, so these these files follow you around This also means, by extension, that if I install in our package right if i'm in here, and I say install packages,
James Blair: let's do,
James Blair: Some saw the line package, then this package will install into my home directory as a user package, and then it will be available to me,
James Blair: persistently from that point forward so I don't need to reinstall packages every time I start a new session and SageMaker those packages are persistent and and follow me into whatever session I happen to be running out,
James Blair: And we can see those packages installed here we can see the user library that our packages i've installed to my own home directory,
James Blair: And then below that we can see the system packages on the SageMaker instance, so that default instance that we selected contains a large number of kind of commonly used data science packages so you'll see in here we have scroll down a little bit,
James Blair: We have the tidy verse in here we have data table in here we have a number of kind of common data manipulation and data modeling packages that are made available here inside of of theSageMaker SageMaker image by default,
James Blair: Okay, so, while this is continuing to run down here let's go ahead and look at a couple of,
James Blair: Other things that we can do right so we're in RStudio and for our users, this is an environment that we're likely comfortable in,
James Blair: So I can, if I want to you from i'm from in here, I can start a new shiny application if I wanted to i'm in this might take a minute, while this in package install wraps up in fact let's come back,
James Blair: here,
James Blair: we're going to open RStudio back up and drop into our,
James Blair: If we can maybe be frozen everything,
James Blair: Okay, once this pulls up we're going to drop into our webinar environment that we have set up already the running session that we currently have for the the arsenio SageMaker webinar see if we can get this to unfreeze maybe,
James Blair: Of course, live demos are always exciting and things never go as planned,
James Blair: Maybe it'll come up for us, if not we'll switch to another environment and try it in there,
James Blair: This is my This is my fault for waiting off script that's what I get,
James Blair: oops,
James Blair: There we go okay alright so let's come in we'll leave that one running but let's come into this environment this session that we have running,
James Blair: Again, one of the advantages, is that other sessions kind of tied up, but we can jump into this session and and go from here so,
James Blair: i'm again i'm in my RStudio environment let's just examine a couple of things that we can do just to verify that things kind of work and behave the way that we would expect them to So if I start if I create a new file, I can create a new shiny application will call that shiny,
James Blair: shiny example go ahead and create that,
James Blair: I can run this here within SageMaker i'll see in fact let's run it in the you were paying here,
James Blair: So I can run this here, I can see the behavior that I would expect, which is, I have my rendered shiny application running over here,
James Blair: I can do what I would expect to do, which is interact with that application if I wanted to I could then publish this application to a place, like RStudio connector shiny apply oh,
James Blair: Obviously this application doesn't have any real consequences significance, but this is evidence that if I wanted to and, and this is likely, the case,
James Blair: I can use SageMaker to do things like fully developed my internal training application that I might then share on our internal RStudio connect platform or some other some other mechanism,
James Blair: So shiny works as I would expect it to tools like plumber also work if we come in here and say let's start new plumber a guy will call this example plumber,
James Blair: We can see my plumber file running here, I can run, this in fact let's do that in the viewer pain again there we go,
James Blair: So I can run this API in here, and again I have the behavior that I would expect right,
James Blair: And, and the nice thing about this, and the reason that i'm going through kind of these simple examples is to highlight that once you're into this environment it works as you would expect i'm able to,
James Blair: install our package is i'm able to write our code i'm able to interact with our documents in the way that I would expect, whether those are source code files like a shiny application or just a script file that i'm working on, or something like a our markdown document or,
James Blair: you'd like plumber API or any number of other things,
James Blair: So, now that we've kind of verified some of those basic functionality, that I think the natural next question, and this was kind of my next question once I once I started getting into this and becoming more familiar with SageMaker, and that was okay,
James Blair: I understand the significance in the advantage from the administrative standpoint I don't need to maintain infrastructure, I have a flexible environment i've got scalable compute resources, I have a lot of convenience,
James Blair: On the administrative side when I allowSageMaker to manage the environment for me,
James Blair: But as an our user, what do I get do I just get RStudio it's just running somewhere else, because in most cases I don't as they are us I don't necessarily care about where RStudio is running, I just want to make sure that I have access to it,
James Blair: But the question in my mind was Is there something that I can now do that was difficult to do before,
James Blair: And then the answer to that is yes there's a lot of functionality within SageMaker that becomes very easy and kind of natural to work with once you're inside of this environment,
James Blair: And so we're going to pull open an example document here i'm not going to spend a ton of time and just another note,
James Blair: All of the kind of code and everything that we look at here is is available on github and i'll share a link at the end of the presentation that will take you to the github repository of the slides will be there,
James Blair: Any source code or examples, or anything that we look at will be there as well, so don't feel like you need to frantically try to copy and paste and follow along everything's available and will be shared, after the fact, so i'm going to open up this is an our markdown notebook here,
James Blair: Let me just yeah okay,
James Blair: So we're not going to walk through this entire thing it's it's a fairly lengthy document and i'll be honest, this is pulled from an example Jupiter notebook that Amazon has provided so there's a github repository that Amazon has that,
James Blair: contains a whole host of SageMaker resources examples getting started guides all kinds of just resources to become familiar with some of the SageMaker features,
James Blair: So this particular example here is pulled directly from a Jupiter notebook that they provide that walks through how to interact with SageMaker via vr,
James Blair: And so i'm going to highlight some of the patterns and again i'm not going to walk in depth through every thing that's here but i'm just going to highlight some of the patterns and functionality that's available,
James Blair: And how we make use of it from within this RStudio environment that happens to be running on SageMaker now, the first thing we ever going to do, I mean just so we can start clean i'm going to restart my session here,
James Blair: Okay now um I mentioned this previously as one of the strengths of the RStudio development, environment, and that was the fact that it works really well as kind of in,
James Blair: On the front end but but it provides some tooling around Python interoperability right if I if i'm working with,
James Blair: Python and are concurrently within the same document, I have some functionality that can help me out with that and that becomes beneficial,
James Blair: Because one of the easiest ways to work with some of theSageMaker tooling as through the SageMaker Python SDK,
James Blair: Now i'm not I don't spend a lot of time in Python i'm much more comfortable in our,
James Blair: But, fortunately, the ridiculous package which allows me to bounce back and forth between R and Python can be used to allow me access to this Python SDK from my from my our session,
James Blair: So that's what we're going to do here at first we're going to load in the particular package we're going to bring in the tidy verse as well, so that we can use the tidy verse for some things later on,
James Blair: And then i'm going to bring in this SageMaker package that's available in Python so here this important function comes from articulate this is loading that SageMaker SDK into my our session, as this SageMaker object i'm going to go ahead and run this,
James Blair: This will load up, I have already set up my Python environment, the default image for,
James Blair: RStudio on SageMaker has articulate already available at the system, the system library so everything should be set up and configured so that you can just kind of hit the ground running,
James Blair: And if we open up my environment, here we can see i've got this SageMaker object that's actually this SageMaker module from Python so this SageMaker object in my our session now gives me access to all the tooling that's available in thatSageMaker Python module,
James Blair: Now we're going to create a couple of different resources that we can use as we go through this process of training and tuning this model,
James Blair: So we're going to create this session object and this bucket that identifies an Amazon s3 bucket that we're going to use to store artifacts data and objects that we create throughout the course of this of this document,
James Blair: And then, one of the really I think convenient features of running RStudio directly inside of SageMaker, is the fact that,
James Blair: I don't have to i'm already permission right like the the role that I have when I open up and start runningSageMaker, is the role that I,
James Blair: assume whenever I execute any of theseSageMaker commands so I don't need to re authenticate myself to Amazon,
James Blair: that's that permission is already scoped in attached to me as I, as I start running here,
James Blair: So I can grab that role, right here by running this get execution role function and notice as i'm interacting here right i'm using this SageMaker module that we see here,
James Blair: And this SageMaker module is a Python module that i've loaded into my our session,
James Blair: And so I access the methods and different objects attached that module with this dollar sign, just as if I was manipulating you know, a list or other object here in inside of our,
James Blair: So here i'm running these different functions of these different methods off of SageMaker to to get this functionality,
James Blair: Okay, so what we're gonna do is we're and again a lot of this comes directly from this Jupiter notebook but we're going to pull down this avalon a data set that comes from the uci machine learning repository,
James Blair: we're going to do a little bit of manipulation on that data set not anything super crazy we're going to download it,
James Blair: will notice that the if we scroll over the sex column here is a character column, but it really should be factors, because we only have three different levels here so we'll go ahead and change that to be a factor,
James Blair: We can look at a summary of what this dataset now looks like and we see that in height, we have some that have zero height,
James Blair: And we want to take a look at what those are so we can go ahead and use GG plot to investigate those,
James Blair: We see a couple of outliers here, and then we have some infants over here and we've added some Judo to this just so that we can gain more visibility into the data, but we can see that we have a couple of observations over here that are infants,
James Blair: That are that have zero height reported so we're going to go ahead and remove any observations, where the height value is zero,
James Blair: And now we're going to go through and we're going to prepare this data set for training so we're going to come in here and we're going to,
James Blair: create these kind of one hot encoding columns for the second column, and then remove the the second column itself,
James Blair: The other thing that we're going to do is we're going to move rings, which is the target of our machine learning model that we're going to build we're going to move that into the first column of our data set,
James Blair: SageMaker expects the first column, to be the target value when you define models and so, in order to comply with that we're going to move rings over here to the front,
James Blair: Okay now we're going to split up our data so that we can get training on this we're going to go ahead and,
James Blair: sample 70% of our data for training and then the remaining 30% we're going to split in half and half half for testing and half for validation,
James Blair: And we're doing that here, and again i'm not going to step through everything the other The other thing to highlight a couple of things to highlight, as we kind of ran this example out is,
James Blair: One like this is not intended to be an example of totally great and and perfect machine learning practices rather the intention here is to kind of highlight,
James Blair: How to use some of the SageMaker features and functionality from within RStudio,
James Blair: And then the other thing to note is that I am by no means a SageMaker expert so somebody like I,
James Blair: becoming more and more familiar, as we go and thankfully, we have some folks from Amazon on the line today is, as we get questions, towards the end that might be able to help and provide some guidance there,
James Blair: um but just worth noting that that you know i'm by no means consider myself a SageMaker expert,
James Blair: Okay, so we're going to go ahead and trim down our data set to be only 500 euros,
James Blair: And the reason for this is because we want to do some stuff towards the end where we're going to submit predictions to there we're going to submit data for prediction to an endpoint that we deploy,
James Blair: And we have to have the the maximum payload we can submit as 500 rounds so we're going to go ahead and trim down our test set to be 500 rows here,
James Blair: And then we're going to write this data out as csv files to our local directory now the reason we write these data, this data out a csv files is so that we can,
James Blair: upload it to s3 and that's what we're gonna do here we're going to create these different files in s3 that represent our training validation and test data,
James Blair: Okay, and then we're going to define these input types, so that when we train our models SageMaker knows what data is dealing with so we're going to create these train input and validation input types that just identify where the data is living and what type of data, it is,
James Blair: OK,
James Blair: Now we're going to go ahead and start getting ready to train our extra boost model,
James Blair: So say Jamaica has ready made containers for training certain types of models actually boosting is one of those model types,
James Blair: So here we can go ahead and retrieve this model here this container definition and, if we look at this and, again, this is all using that SageMaker SDK that we've loaded into our session,
James Blair: Here we can see here's where the containers living and we can reference that as we go through our training process,
James Blair: Now we're going to define our estimator again i'm not going to go through everything that's that's available here,
James Blair: All this content will be available for we're going to go ahead and define the estimated that we want to use by providing it with the container that we want to train with,
James Blair: The instance type that we want to do our training on and where the output should go from that model and things of that nature,
James Blair: Now, once we've defined what our estimator is, we can go through and define hyper parameters that we want to explore and how we,
James Blair: plan on tuning those hyper parameters again i'm not going to walk through everything that's that's involved here, but the idea is again i'm making use of this SageMaker module that's available to me in my our session through the SageMaker object,
James Blair: we're also identifying our validation metric here,
James Blair: Now, once this is all said and done, we can build the tuner that we're going to use to,
James Blair: tune our model we can give this job and name define our input data so here's the path and s3 or that input data is stored here's the path and s3 where the validation of data is stored,
James Blair: And then, finally, we can use this fit method of this tuner object that we created to actually fit this tuner which will go through and explore this hyper parameter space that we've that we've defined and identify the best fitting model,
James Blair: Now this job is now kicked off and the thing that's significant to understand is we've defined this training, job,
James Blair: entirely to be run and managed by SageMaker right so again we're using are using RStudio but we've use,
James Blair: These tools to orchestrate this training, job that is now being executed by SageMaker itself,
James Blair: And if we scroll back up just a little bit to see where we define our estimator, we can see that we've defined an instance type that we're going to run this training, job on,
James Blair: And we've defined some other attributes so that sage baker knows when we fit this this tuner and we, and we, and we, when we,
James Blair: Train this model, it goes out and provisions, the necessary resources grabs the appropriate container that has all the available and necessary dependencies,
James Blair: To run this train this X GB model and then runs through that training, job in a totally separate environment,
James Blair: that's why, when we ran this if we come back down to where we're fitting our tuner here scroll down there we go if we, when we look at how we ran this, we can see that our our session isn't tied up right, we can still I can still do things here in the console it's,
James Blair: I have, I still haven't a listening session because my our session isn't being used to do the model training,
James Blair: it'sSageMaker manage resources that are handling the model training at this point now I can query that process, to see how far along it is using both three, which is another Python SDK for,
James Blair: For Amazon services so again will follow the same pattern that we use with SageMaker will load in this photo three module as an object, and then we can query our SageMaker,
James Blair: tuning job by running a few commands from this photo three library So here we can see, I have for in progress models, the job status is currently in progress,
James Blair: Know models of yet succeeded and no models of yet failed, and if I look back up here just a little bit, I can see that I set this Max parallel jobs parameter when I set up my tuner to before,
James Blair: So that's why we see for parallel training jobs, taking place, and I have a maximum jobs set to be 10 so once i've gone through 10 different iterations here this particular tuning will be complete and we'll be able to extract what the best model was from that from that process,
James Blair: Go ahead and run this one more time and see if we've completed any yet,
James Blair: We see that we still have four in progress models so i'll let that continue running and just kind of talk through what the rest of this would look like once we've,
James Blair: run this model, we can then grab what the best training, job was out of the status of of the the tuning job that we've we've run,
James Blair: We can investigate what the metrics are of that model, and we can also figure out where that model is being stored inside of s3 so we have lots of functionality around how we manipulate the models that get created from our tuning jobs,
James Blair: And then, at this point, we have two different options right but typically the point of building a model isn't just to build the model itself,
James Blair: But to then do something with it right to leverage that modeling some way to run new data through the model and generate predictions on that new data,
James Blair: And SageMaker provides kind of two frameworks for doing that one is batch transformations which is i'm not necessarily looking for real time in,
James Blair: In France, but rather i'm looking for a way to run a batch of new data through my model all at one time,
James Blair: And that's that's something that's supported through the SageMaker SDK,
James Blair: This walks through an example of setting up and i'm not i'm not going to walk through right now, but this walk through an example of how to set up that batch transformation and run a set of new test data through the model,
James Blair: collect those results and then compare them to the original observations so that's one option, the other option here is you scroll down a little bit,
James Blair: Thank you, the other option which is one that all focus on here for a moment, is deploying the model,
James Blair: SageMaker provides native tooling for being able to take a model that's been training SageMaker and deploy it directly into into SageMaker itself as an endpoint,
James Blair: And then from that end point you can now generate real time predictions by submitting either http requests to the endpoint,
James Blair: through other tools like you might create a shiny application that queries that endpoint and generates real time request based on user input,
James Blair: You might have a front end mobile application that it's built within the organization that queries this model through this deployed endpoint that you create,
James Blair: there's like it like I mentionedSageMaker has native support for deploying these endpoints for certain types of models this actually be model that we've trained here is is one such example of those,
James Blair: And so, here we can see, we use this to play method on our tuner object to deploy this model into this environment,
James Blair: And then, once that model has been deployed, we can define a serialized or for it and we can use,
James Blair: This predict method, on the model itself to submit requests to that end point generate predictions and bring those predictions back into our existing our session yeah let me come back up and just see if our tuning Java, has made any progress here,
James Blair: And we can take a look at rap,
James Blair: So we have four succeeded models, we have four models that are currently in progress being trained,
James Blair: not going to wait for that to conclude, but we see that we're making progress here and we can continue to query that progress using this photo free library that we've brought into our our session now i'm going to come back into let me see if I can get back into it here,
James Blair: Okay, so here i'm in i'm in SageMaker, this is the the SageMaker studio so the Jupiter lab interface, and the one other thing that I wanted to highlight is if I come down here,
James Blair: I can see this either SageMaker resources view that's available to me here,
James Blair: And I can come in, and I can look at this endpoint section, and I can see, these are previously deployed endpoints that I have have published in preparation for our discussion today so here, I can see, these are both,
James Blair: Models trained on the same data just under two separate days, but I can come in here and click on one of these, and I can open up an entire view into what that model looks like,
James Blair: And here I can submit test request to the model I can view what the you know what how this model set up what the endpoint for the model is,
James Blair: Information about the runtime of the model if I had specified that I wanted to enable model tracking I could view things like quality explain ability bias,
James Blair: These types of metrics are supportive in SageMaker, as long as I configure my deployment to to allow for tracking and metric collection, which I haven't done in this case,
James Blair: But, but it is something that's available if that's something that's of interest now to back up a little bit right if we come back here for a second,
James Blair: what's you know what what's the big deal what's the excitement about this well there's kind of two things one is maybe the the depending on the perspective might be the less exciting of the of the,
James Blair: The two things here but, but that is the fact that you can as an RStudio customer, you can bring existing RC to workbench licenses,
James Blair: into SageMaker and use RStudio workbench within your SageMaker environment now you have an entirely managed hosted solution of RStudio workbench,
James Blair: You don't need to worry about maintaining installing updating or anything like that, but it remains flexible and gives you lots of resources at your disposal for doing your day to day analysis inside of a native RStudio environment,
James Blair: The other thing that we've just looked at, is once you're in that environment as an our user you gain access to a whole collection of,
James Blair: SageMaker tools from model, training and tuning to deployment monitoring all those things are now available to you directly from within your sage connector environment now today,
James Blair: That access is managed through ridiculous like We walked through in the example just now so using the ridiculous package, we can bring in the SageMaker SDK,
James Blair: And then we can use that to interact with the safe environment from model, training and tuning to deployment and any other things that we might want to interact with,
James Blair: Now kind of as we look towards the future and what's coming up in this space,
James Blair: One of the kind of immediate term things to be addressed is that there will soon be the ability to bring custom images for RStudio workbench in Amazon SageMaker, so if we come back here just to remind us of what that looks like,
James Blair: If we come back into our home screen here when we start a new session currently there's only one image available to select from,
James Blair: But that will change in the near future, and there will be the ability to bring additional custom images,
James Blair: into RStudio workbench so you could define your own images within your organization, there may be predefined other images that are available that could contain,
James Blair: Different libraries different versions of our that would that would support the use case that you're after,
James Blair: The other thing that we're really excited about and actually working on bringing to the table is RStudio connect managed by SageMaker in the same way that we see RStudio workbench managed by SageMaker today,
James Blair: Now it is possible today to use RStudio connect and you know,
James Blair: installed and managed within your own environment in connection with RStudio workbench installed and managed by SageMaker,
James Blair: And what that process would look like, as you would develop and do your work inside of RStudio workbench,
James Blair: In this SageMaker, environment and then, when it came time to publish what you were working on you just publish that to connect,
James Blair: and connect my you know, in this case connect would be something that you've installed and managed somewhere else,
James Blair: But down the road we anticipate bringing RStudio connect to SageMaker as well in much in the same way that we have RStudio workbench integrated there today,
James Blair: it's actually when you set up the the RStudio integration on SageMaker, one of the things that you have the ability to do is to predefined you're both RC to connect,
James Blair: URL if you already have an RC to connect environment, you want to automatically,
James Blair: configure that for publishing from workbench you can do that when you set up workbench on SageMaker, and then the other thing is, you can automatically define or you can you can set up and define an RStudio package manager URL for users to use when you go through the setup process,
James Blair: Finally, a few resources we put out a blog post about this announcing this integration, a few weeks ago there's a link to that here,
James Blair: aws has put out a number of different blog posts, and there are two of them are linked from here this this news blog is kind of a general blog,
James Blair: about me just open this up kind of a general blog about what the offering is and what's available today and then this getting started post here is kind of a more technical post the walks through from the administrative side, what do you need to do to set up,
James Blair: RStudio on Amazon SageMaker, how does it work, what do you did you know how do you get the license in into the right place and what do you do, on your SageMaker domain to configure this to work,
James Blair: And then finally there's this there's this github link here, let me open this up,
James Blair: So this github repository contains the slides from today, as well as the example code that we walked through,
James Blair: Like I mentioned that example code pulls from this repository here that's a whole collection of our examples provided by the SageMaker team,
James Blair: These are all in the form of Jupiter notebooks, but they can easily be kind of repurposed or reimagined into centered our scripts are our markdown documents,
James Blair: Whatever the cases, now that RStudio itself is available within this SageMaker environment,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: And, did you copy that github link into the chat as well,
James Blair: yeah I can't,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: miss a painting that question,
James Blair: For me grab that it's a great idea,
James Blair: Perfect all right there we go,
James Blair: Okay, so there's the there's the link to this github repository in the chat So you can see the links to the to the,
James Blair: Additional resources under the slides if you if you open up the slides directory in here, it contains a PDF output of all the slides and that resources page has the resources links that we just discussed,
James Blair: Finally, as much as i'd like to take credit for the funding of these slides I pulled these from an website that made these freely available and i'm grateful for that and and some of the the comic book graphics and things like that we're also provided by free pick,
James Blair: And as a final note, and Thank you everyone for your time today I know there's probably lots of questions and so will will take some time here at the end to to address as many those as we can, or give the folks from Amazon a chance to address those if there's,
James Blair: Some better suited for them,
James Blair: But I just want to say, I really appreciate the time we at RStudio are very excited about this,
James Blair: And I just want to reiterate what turf had mentioned in his question, that is, that we're committed to continuing to build out this integration we were really excited about the momentum we've seen,
James Blair: we're really excited about the early adoption that we've seen,
James Blair: And personally just, from my perspective, i'm really excited about the capabilities that this introduces into the ecosystem and i'm excited to see what,
James Blair: What things people are now able to do with the solution that perhaps previously were unavailable or more difficult to do,
James Blair: And now that we have this theSageMaker integration directly available so with that i'll i'll see what questions we have, I think there's folks that have been watching this the slide oh link so reach I don't know,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: about having a,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: happy to happy to help with that, and thank you so much, James that was awesome and those slides are beautiful,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: And so I, we do also have some people on from the Amazon SageMaker team as well who you may have seen we're helping answer questions and slide out to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: And so I just want to take a second to have them introduce themselves as well, Michael and Georgios see if you want to jump on for a second,
Michael Hsieh [AWS]: I am, my name is Michael sure,
Michael Hsieh [AWS]: I'm a machine learning specialist from aws thanks for having having me for today's session really looking forward to have conversations on our [], thank you,
Georgios Schinas (AWS): hello, for me, as well, my name is George is seen as i'm listening, especially solutions architect, as well as Michael and based in London and i'm really happy to be here today, and hopefully can answer questions that the Community has,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: Some Thank you and i'll start by going through the slido questions and the ones that are the most up voted, but we want to make sure to answer everything as well, so,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: i've talked with Lou on our team about writing a blog post that goes through all the Q amp a as well and, but just to address this one James the most voted question was do you need a paid RStudio workbench license in order to use RStudio and SageMaker,
James Blair: Yes,
James Blair: The the way that we've shown this integration today, it only works with a paid RStudio workbench license,
James Blair: And that can be just to elaborate on that a little bit further that can be either standard, which is a licensed for one server one activation or enterprise which gives you unlimited server activations,
James Blair: On both of those models will work with SageMaker, if you if you do standard then SageMaker becomes your one installation of RStudio if you have enterprise,
James Blair: You could be running RStudio and SageMaker, as well as have your own on Prem solution, you know you can you have lots of flexibility at that point,
James Blair: But, but the answer that question is yes, it does require a license for us to do workbench,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: Thank you, and I see Eduardo you asked a question that a lot of people about voted as well and i'd love to hear from the Community to if you want to read that question and bardot if you're still on,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: And I can I can read it now, if you want to add any more context, please feel free to jump in,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: But the question was how to sage make your help ml solutions designed with our into production is there, specific ml package that SageMaker can deal with, for example, tidy models or carrot,
James Blair: yeah I can speak to that with my like I said i'm not a SageMaker expert so i'm happy to be corrected by the folks on the on the Amazon side as well, but from my understanding today right the,
James Blair: Most of the functionality, when you,
James Blair: When you interact directly with with SageMaker, is going to come through that SageMaker Python SDK so like we use articulate we brought that,
James Blair: module in, and then we use methods and functions from that module to manipulate and train a model and deploy the model and all those types of things,
James Blair: Now, one of the kind of underlying components of that is the fact that all that that whole process that model training tuning deployment processes all actually happening in Python right that the container that we ran was running actually boost and,
James Blair: interacting with that via Python we were managing it from the outside, with articulate, but most of the work was being done on the Python side,
James Blair: Now there is support in SageMaker, for being able to define kind of your own custom containers and images from model, training and deployment, where you could define ways to interact with our processes,
James Blair: But to my understanding today there's not a lot of native our tooling there yet now that's something i'd love to see change and something that i'm hopeful will change over time as this,
James Blair: Partnership continues to grow and expand that's i've had discussions with folks about what some changes i'd like to see, for example, and this is,
James Blair: This is an indication that this will happen, but my own personal just you know utopian future would be that there is an our native SDK,
James Blair: For SageMaker that allows our users to natively interact with a Jamaican resources, as well as support for things like tidy models and say Jamaica now,
James Blair: there's a lot of work to be done to get there, and again this isn't a promise that that will ever come to fruition, but you know it's something that i'd like to work towards, and it would love to see happen,
Michael Hsieh [AWS]: And today, you know this is Michael so I like to add on what chance has has provided in seesmic or you can different bring in your,
Michael Hsieh [AWS]: Containers so you can package your trading models corralled into a container and started training and also hosting,
Michael Hsieh [AWS]: Your models built natively within her into SageMaker, and then you know i'm doing all the mo hops CCD along with seesmic you're using the ch mckay's K within your environment, so we do have a couple resources and an artifact showing how to do so, so happy to share those information,
awesome Thank you Michael,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: And James I know you address this question a bit towards the end, but I think it'd be good to address as well, but she got asked is a good solution for host Is this a good solution for hosting in developing shiny applications,
James Blair: yeah so for developing absolutely right, it gives you a valid environment where you can develop these shiny applications and the nice thing is, you can develop these applications,
James Blair: In a way, that natively reaches out to and interacts with your aws resources, so it becomes really easy because you're already operating inside of aws,
James Blair: To read data in from s3 and to interact with other aws resources without needing to worry about like credential management,
James Blair: Now that's on the development side on the like publication and hosting side, the story is a little bit different today because,
James Blair: Currently, RStudio connect which would be kind of the preferred method of deploying and hosting China applications,
James Blair: isn't something that's offered through SageMaker that's that's The next step for us is making that available and it's something that's that's under current conversation to have done,
James Blair: And so we're hopeful that that will be available shortly,
James Blair: But in the meantime, what that means is you would develop inside of RStudio workbench on SageMaker, and then you would publish or deploy that application,
James Blair: To some other location, whether that's RStudio connect you have separately installed and managed somewhere else,
James Blair: or shiny Apps I O or some other solution, and the challenge with that is the fact that once you kind of cross that boundary and you're no longer operating inside of that kind of SageMaker domain,
James Blair: Now you have to start thinking about like how do I, you know if i'm interacting with other aws services, for example, like s3 now I need to make sure that I have my credentials under control, and I know what i'm doing in terms of like authenticating with the service,
James Blair: When when RStudio connect becomes available throughSageMaker, I imagine that that story will become a little bit more clear because you'll be able to publish directly from workbench onSageMaker to connect on SageMaker,
James Blair: And you'll still have that seemed kind of Nice native authentication that's already taken place,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: awesome Thank you and,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: Ryan, I see you asked a question around advantages of using tidy models within SageMaker, would you want to jump on and and add any context to that question, too,
Rayan Azhari: I can you hear me,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: Yes, I can yeah,
Rayan Azhari: Thank you very much, I think, partly this question was answered,
Rayan Azhari: was just asking if tidy models taken advantage of SageMaker, and whether it's trans in a separate environment, but as James said at the moment Python is doing the heavy heavy lifting,
James Blair: yeah that's that's correct, I again I would love to you know, this is still early stage for us we're,
James Blair: Beyond excited about what we're seeing, and you know what we see as we look towards the future and will will continue to work towards that future and with with the SageMaker team,
James Blair: I would love to see you know, like SageMaker added as an engine on the tidy model side again,
James Blair: Whether that happens, or not remains to be seen, but I can see ways in which that could happen,
James Blair: But, but again you're you're entirely correct and the fact that today if you're trying to do use some of the native tooling and technology with what's available primarily on the Python side, thankfully, we do have a good entry point in there be articulate,
James Blair: But i'm hoping that kind of the art aspect will start to kind of build out over time here as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: Great Thank you music, I see is a great great question as well from the zoom chat and I think he copied over to slide out to if you don't ask that one line,
Maisie Moore: short,
Maisie Moore: winded again oh yeah So when I before I saw the RStudio launching this studio lab and,
Maisie Moore: maker I I started kind of building a workflow with the art colonel in the notebook instance, and so I wanted to just know like what would be the difference between or what would,
Maisie Moore: You what would be the difference between using the art colonel in the notebook instance versus like RStudio and the studio,
James Blair: yeah really good question it's like functionality wise there's not going to be much of a difference in terms of like what you can or can't do, or what types of workflows are aren't supported,
James Blair: really what it comes down to I think is just a preference right, I like if i'm comfortable using the Ark colonel in the native kind of,
James Blair: Jupiter style environment, then, then I can do that and, and I can interact with my environment that way,
James Blair: But we found, and one of the main motivating factors behind this whole integration has been that,
James Blair: Many our users have kind of sage megan said look we'd really love to have RStudio because it's home to us right we feel comfortable we know what to do it just it's it's,
James Blair: Where we have fewer barriers to entry when we're using in RStudio type environment and so,
James Blair: it's really just kind of an environmental preference right I I myself and much more comfortable in RStudio that I am inside of Jupiter so any chance, I have to work inside of an RStudio environment when using our,
James Blair: Is is something that i'm going to jump out so in terms of functionality I don't think you have really any significant differences it's just a matter of preference in terms of which environment suits suits you better,
Maisie Moore: got it Thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: Thank you, and next question was an anonymous one that was is RStudio workbench fully onSageMaker, or is that using SageMaker, is a launcher back in which would still require a front end work,
James Blair: bench sad oh man it's such a good question, I meant to talk to this point because it's a it's a very nuanced question but it's a good one, so,
James Blair: When you set up your SageMaker domain to support RStudio one of the things that you do is you identify a persistent instance that will host RStudio,
James Blair: So so you're right there does need to be some persistent environment that runs that then launches these sessions into into SageMaker and allows a maker to manage the resources behind those sessions,
James Blair: So there is that persistent environment um I believe the default and it doesn't need to be very big because there's not any computation happening there,
James Blair: That environment gets automatically provision for you and you set up this inside your SageMaker domain and you can decide what instance type you want i'm trying to remember, I think T three medium,
James Blair: Is kind of the default and I believe that SageMaker gives that to you for free like as part of the RC offering on SageMaker that that host environment that's just running constantly to support the RStudio front end is there and it's but it's it's still maintained by SageMaker,
Sean Morgan (AWS): And I don't believe it's it's,
James Blair: Something that's charged for,
Georgios Schinas (AWS): yep that's just a quick comment on that James you're right, both on the instance type it's three medium and it's also free,
James Blair: perfect, thank you for confirming,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: awesome and there's another question that was what are the expectations for Environment management is it managed by aws or studio me will I have access to the same environment two years from now, to maintain reproducibility,
James Blair: yeah so so there's,
James Blair: I think there's two sides to this question,
James Blair: Because environment can mean a couple of things, so one is like your local our environment is is within your control so if you want, you know you can install packages,
James Blair: Those will go into your home directory that home directory is persistent like we mentioned so different sessions that start will have the same access to the same files and packages that you are working with previously,
James Blair: And what that means is that you know there's support for thing is automatically because of that fact is automatically support for things like rem So if you wanted to create,
James Blair: A very specific collection of packages for a very specific project and have those version to a very specific set of versions that's totally supported through tools like rm,
James Blair: You know income in combination with with what you're getting out of SageMaker, so your local environment totally within your control and certainly you can set it up, so that you can come back to that environment,
James Blair: Two years down the road, and you know we instantiated the way that it was, and we continue working from where you left off,
James Blair: The other side of this is what about the administrative environment, you know that the server the settings for for,
James Blair: Our CEO workbench things like that that's something that falls under the SageMaker control understands makers control right so when you,
James Blair: Say look i'm going to set up and manage RStudio workbench through SageMaker part of what you're doing is saying i'm going to let SageMaker handle that RStudio administrative tasks for me,
James Blair: which can be a huge benefit because I don't have to worry about that stuff anymore, and in this particular you know i'm i'm really excited to see how this helps,
James Blair: We work with a lot of organizations that are very windows centric and all of our software, it needs to be installed Linux environments and that's sometimes is a big hurdle to overcome,
James Blair: now listen, you can say look i'm just gonna let SageMaker manage and hosted for me and I don't need to worry about all the Linux stuff behind the scenes, as long as I can work with aws to get the domain setup right,
James Blair: Then i've got an environment, I can use,
James Blair: But the other thing that that means is that i'm letting SageMaker handle that, for me, so if there's questions or concerns or things that I want to adjust it there, you know features that I want enabled or whatever that becomes a conversation, to have a stage,
James Blair: And then, it looks like,
James Blair: Sorry just real quick, there was a clarification in the chat about the it says the question about environments has more to do with system libraries, rather than our packages so,
James Blair: The system libraries component typically will come well two things one is you have currently today when you're in your session running on SageMaker, you have root access to that container,
James Blair: So when you go into the terminal tab of RStudio you have already assumed the role the,
James Blair: role, so you can modify that container as you need so if there's a system dependency that you're in the middle of project you like, oh no I needed this thing,
James Blair: You should be able to get in,
James Blair: add it to that container at that time and and run with it from there now that's not persistent though right So if I if that session terminates in that container goes away and I start a new session i'm going to have to reinstall that dependency at that point,
James Blair: I can do it, but it's not persistent, the other side is this custom image functionality that we anticipate coming to SageMaker in the near future, which would allow you to identify at the,
James Blair: docker level as you as you build out these docker files what system dependencies you need available in your environment and that's how you would manage those persistently,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: awesome thanks James and for anyone who asks a question feel free to jump in to add more context to and unmute yourself as well,
James Blair: And I will say let's maybe take one more i'm unfortunately i'm booked back to back so i've got a job,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: minute sorry about that,
James Blair: I would, I would love to hang around and answer all these questions and part of me really wants to but it's irresponsible so let's um let's do one more question that i've gotta i've gotta drop off awesome,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: So one other question is,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: Have you put a lot of pressure on me to ask the,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: Like,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: i'm just gonna go from the most up voted, so it was this many more for Amazon, but will RStudio be available in the new Amazon SageMaker studio lab,
Georgios Schinas (AWS): yeah so um yeah I think I can I can take this question so for now seeds marissa do lab is is only supposed to work with Jupiter lab,
Georgios Schinas (AWS): But if we see that there is no interest from the Community, we can take that feedback and then work with,
Georgios Schinas (AWS): With you guys from the studio side to see if we can somehow find a good solution, good how the whole Community,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: So thank you and James I know you have to drop to another meeting and to the Amazon team, do you have a few more minutes, do you have to to jump as well,
Georgios Schinas (AWS): Myself, I also have another meeting to go to,
Georgios Schinas (AWS): Okay yeah well we try to answer some questions from the top, on the I guess the slide two will remain open from know Sagan yes,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: This slide Oh, I mean have been and what we can also do is take all the questions from slider and answer those in a blog post format as well, so i'll share that with the recording,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: Once we have that available, so the recording will go up to the RStudio YouTube before tomorrow and then we'll work on that Q amp a blog post too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: But I also just wanted to give anyone else from the Amazon side a moment to introduce themselves as well, I know a few people from the Amazon sales team were on as well, you may have had to drop but,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: If anyone's here feel free to unmute yourself and jump into,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: Well, thank you all so much for joining there's so many great questions I really appreciate it and we'll do our best to make sure that we answer every single one of them and,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: i'm happy to stick around for just like general questions around resources or meetups or anything that you have but, unfortunately, no jeans and the aws team have to jump but thank you all so much for joining,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her) | RStudio: Have a great rest of the day,